uno de los atractivos de dividir y
promediar es que es muy fácil de
programar entonces solamente hay que
encontrar el punto medio que es
justamente un promedio de coordenadas
esto facilitó mucho para que las
personas que hicieron nuestro software
crearán herramientas intuitivas para
artistas como yo que hacemos personajes
algo así como lo que usaste para modelar
la sonrisa en la siguiente versión
interactiva reemplazamos los botones de
división y promedió con uno solo llamado
subdividir al darle clic simplemente
hace una división seguida de un promedio
concéntrate en esta región de la curva
ahora vamos a extender estas líneas
hasta que choquen con el control del
polígono
no se ve esto sospechosamente parecido a
la construcción con hilos que vimos en
los arcos parabólicos
ahora veamos qué pasa cuando subdividido
de nuevo el patrón de hilos continúa
surgiendo cada vez que damos clic en
subdividir obtenemos el doble de hilos y
significa que la curva que estamos
creando es un arco parabólico en esta
región y hay otro arco parabólico por
acá y por acá y por acá pero mágicamente
estos cuatro arcos se combinan
suavemente entre ellos esto es genial si
a alguien le interesan las matemáticas
este es el tipo de sorpresas que me
emocionan
el siguiente ejercicio pondrá a prueba
que también entiendes este concepto